[Music]
foreign
you gotta admit i'm surprised
i didn't think they'd recover so fast we
tried everything
normal forms of interrogation weren't
working breaking a subject's will and
erasing their mind
is a difficult and painful process
that's a small price to pay
the cia's mind control program has had a
great deal of success with implanted
memories
you want me to tell them about my time
in vietnam lastly
you'll need
we've known each other for years fought
together played together
been through the hell of vietnam
together we've got a job to do
and now the training is complete you
just need to give the subject a name
bill
he's coming too
bell no more [ __ ] around what did
perseus say
where is he
what you're going through now is nothing
compared to what you'll experience if
you don't start cooperating
we gave you a second chance when you
were [ __ ] out of luck
now we just want some assistance in
return bill
you were one of perseus's agents his
associate arash cardovar turned on you
at the airstrip in turkey
left you for dead
when the plane leaves traps on is
stopping in dugo
this you know here's what you don't know
perseus won't be there none of these
hired guns are going to leave dugout
alive
we'll dump their bodies in the forest
then we will move the weapons to volkov
in berlin
from there we fly to solovetsky
but i have other plans for you first is
things too highly of you
i don't want the competition
we were there we found you after
everything went down
the cia reinvented you bell
we needed to give you a new identity to
replace the old
in the end no specific background really
stuck with you
you resisted everything we tried so we
just kept it a mystery
and we were able to utilize your
language and cryptography skills as an
added bonus
[Music]
the bigger challenge was your memory
the cia's mk ultra program used adler's
missions in vietnam as a template
we needed you to have that shared
experience that lifelong bond
to establish trust
no count yourself lucky you've only had
those memories for a few months
me i've been living with them for over a
decade
interrogation didn't work with you but
thanks to mk ultra's research we had a
backup plan
if you believed you were someone else we
could lead you to a place where you'd
give everything up
[Music]
enough to get us where we are today but
we're not finished yet
we have a job to do well we've got come
on
got a job tomorrow
the trigger phrase kept you in line but
it didn't get us everything we needed
your innermost secrets were always
locked behind the door
bell i realize you probably hate us
right now
what we've done to you i just need you
to fully understand the stakes here
what you do right now is not about me
it's not about you
it's about millions of other [ __ ]
people
it's about stopping someone who in the
end has no true
allegiance to anyone other than himself
so tell me where is perseus
once we control the green light we will
detonate them all from the safety of
where is perseus
[Music]
sims get washington on the line everyone
else gear up we're leaving now
you made the right choice bell come on
you're still one of us
versus the cia's analysts consider him
to be the single
largest threat to the free world you've
been given an important task
protecting our very way of life from a
great evil
the united states and its allies slowly
consume
that which is dear to us we are hours
away from purchase detonating nuclear
bombs in every major european city
we'll do whatever it takes
[Music]
some of us will cross the line to make
sure the line's still there in the
morning
no one's gonna brand us heroes or
villains
they don't know us as for me
i've been chasing this ghost for 13
years
that ends now
[Music]
that baby hits we'll have 12 minutes
passed before the radio towers come back
online
our job is to knock out the aea guns and
give our war birds a clean shot
let's take perseus off the air
[Music]
lots of bad guys
[Music]
watch up push up go go
rpg
break down
[Music]
hey guns straight ahead rpg
what's up
this boys
videos
[Music]
now take out that a gun
stand back it's hot
[Music]
nice work bell head for the church
clear out ndaa gods on the west wing
you know that's not good enough i can't
risk an early strike
we only got one shot at this you don't
think i know that
just be ready to launch when i tell you
hudson
[Music]
contact
[Music]
take him down
[Music]
dude
the power's coming back on
you better hurry the [ __ ] up
okay
that mg's
any minute
radio towers are still floating up we
got a chance
[Music]
no we gotta go now
they did it mr president they stopped
the nukes
thank god and the cia did they get
perseus
no sir his whereabouts are unknown and a
russian response
nothing yet we're seeing signs of
confusion
it's possible this was all a rogue
operation
perseus may not have been following
orders from moscow
well i'll be damned maybe we have
something in common after all
we stopped him